especially Scotland the Escalade from
Darren I mean my fight was against the
police I understand like it wasn't
coming out to loot shops or again
because offer these shops went on the
high road to getting our people that we
live with every day you understand that
we taught you to engage with every day
so understand say wasn't like we planned
to do what happened and the other people
him that kind of took mark situation and
as an excuse to run up in shops and
still chain of stuff yet
it's me off with very much disappointing
because we me my fight was against the
police and so my my argument to them was
that what did you scan for did you come
out here ask for that name especially if
you got arrested and sent to jail you
know you but you went to jumped steers
on trainers or stealing a bottle of
water sorry get in the know you have no
respect for anyone that took more
situation has an exclusive store some
free stuff I mean the only thing I
regret is the innocent people that was
affected by the riots ie people's homes
businesses then gave me in lives
I'm not wearing for the rights to happen
again I understand
no I'm trying to make some sort of
change to get me to break that cycle